好 大家早安
現在時間是8月31的早上6點45
那我們就來復盤一下剛才的這個夜盤
那我們今天就直接爆雷啦
今天的夜盤非常的精彩
就是在一個夜盤裡面我們打了20單的短單
然後最後扣掉每單一點的交易成本是賺75點
那當然每個人會有不同的滑價要再扣掉
那就是雖然看起來20單好像非常的複雜
不過看過我幾次交易實戰復盤的觀眾應該都可以看出來
就是我交易的其中一個特色就是我的進出場的依據都是非常非常明確的
就是有非常明確的量化的數學規定
那只要你學會了這一套規定
你的進場跟出場位置跟我都會基本上是完全一樣的
那當然如果因為心理因素你這個下單有一些這個不停損或提早停利的話
那這個當然就不是這個數學策略的考量
那不然的話基本上大家都可以達到一樣的點位
然後我會有一些這個停損跟停利的調整
不過這些調整的規則也都是非常明確的
就是基本上都跟創新高新低有一些關係
那看過我幾次影片的話也大概可以知道我這些規則是什麼
好那這也是我比較理想的這個交易策略模式
就是你的進場跟出場的規定都是不需要任何的主觀判斷的這個量化輔助的策略
好那我們就來看一下今天的規盤
我們就從9點半美股開盤的時候開始看好了
因為這個9點半之前就都不太會有爆大量的情況
然後好我們就看到了今天的低跟大量
那它的低點是954嘛
所以就掛好這個953的出價空單
好然後這邊就進到了953
那這個risk的算法的話就是高點減低點再加2
那因為我們是在953進嘛
然後會在高點加1tick
969的地方掛停損
所以就是會是高減低再加2是你的risk
所以這一單的risk是16
那16乘2是32
所以953-32是921
那這樣的話就可以這個非常快的心算算出來
你的停損停一點位是要掛在哪邊
跟大家講一下
這個比較快的算法是怎樣
好然後這邊進了一個-953
然後
OK
然後這邊如果這個長過的話就會
反向多單嘛
OK
然後
喔然後這邊就有到921了
所以到這邊921就停立了一個32點
算是一個蠻不錯的開場
然後這個是紅K嘛
所以如果跌破的話會進空單
那這一根紅K的實戰是
它是先碰到下面然後才上來
那這個大家自己去看Ticker就可以知道
實戰確實是這樣的情形
就是
不是先上去然後才下來的
那所以這一根
這一個1分K是會直接進一個空單
然後被停損
那所以是一個-914
然後被停損在923的空單
就在同一分鐘就停損了
然後
還是我把這個開在旁邊
讓大家可以看
算了
就-9
還是不要開這個好了
然後
再來是
好
如果這一根
被跌破的話
會進
進空單
好
然後這邊也
確實跌破了
所以是進一個-912的空單
然後
然後這一根的高點是
如果漲過的話
會進927的多單
那這邊剛好又是926
那沒有漲過
所以沒有進多單
然後
OK
然後這邊的高點是908的
大量黑K嘛
所以它被漲過了
那原本是在持有空單
然後
黑K被漲過的話
就會進
兩倍的多單
所以這邊是進
這個
兩倍的
909的多單
好
我
這個
沒事就點開來一下
讓大家
可以
暫停影片來看好了
然後
所以這邊是進一個
兩倍的
909多單
然後
然後這邊就停損了嘛
就是
以這一根的低點
停損
所以這邊會停損
所以這邊是一個
停損
15點
然後
然後這一根
又是
高點又是
所以
這邊
漲過
又進了一次
加909的多單
不過
不是以同一根為EG進場
就是
同一根
大量K棒
我們只會進場一次
那這個看起來都是加909
不過
EG的K棒是不同的
這邊進了一個加909
然後
然後這邊又再停損一次
就是
就是它又剛好點到上面
一下然後又下來
所以這邊又停損在
所以打到這邊的時候是
連續停損了兩單
那
第一單的加32是
的獲利是已經被抵銷掉
不過就是
反正就是按照基本策略打嘛
該多就多
該空就空
也不需要有太多
這個
主觀的
的想法
然後
然後這邊好像都
都沒有
都沒有跌破
然後
這一根
這邊的話就是
就是掛兩邊了
像這種
連續的
400口的
黑K跟紅K
接在一起的話
就是
如果漲過
就會進多單
如果跌破
就會進空單
那所以這邊的話
就是兩邊掛NIT
那這樣的話
就基本上
就一定會進場
就是總不可能
後面的盤
都一直在這兩個
區間裡面
正
那就是掛兩邊
看哪邊發動
好
那所以這邊是
進了這個
呃
減
的空單
然後
呃
高點是
所以聽準是
然後
這根
黑K
被掌過了
所以
減
在這邊
會被
兩倍的
反向
打多單
因為
原本是
只有一倍的空單
要變一倍的多單
所以這邊是
打一個
加
的
兩倍多單
那
像這種情況
就是
你在這個地方
例如說
呃
原本是五口大台
那你這邊就要掛
十口大台的多單
這樣才會讓
負五口變成正五口
好
然後
喔
這邊
是
連續的
這個
就是
大量
然後
這個是
口
所以
這一個地方
是
會有
地眼的
就是
這個地方的
跌破一樣
會
進反向的
空單
所以這邊是
進兩倍的
的
多單
然後
在這邊
跌破
就
又
重新進
兩倍的
反向
的空單
然後
這個
830的空單
是
Risk
加2
乘以2
所以
停力是
在
然後
好
很順利的
就
馬上停力
在這邊
所以這邊是一個
加28點
然後
OK
又出現了一個
紅K
又再被跌破
所以這邊就馬上又再追一個
減
的
空單
因為是
跌破
然後
好
這一根
黑K
被掌過
所以這個是一個
呃
的
兩倍
多單
因為是
空單
要轉多
所以
這一根被掌過
是
加791
兩倍
然後
這一根
也是一個
大量的
黑K
然後
好
我們繼續看好了
所以這一根
呃
這一根大量的
紅K
被跌破
所以這邊會再進一個
兩倍的
的空單
好
因為是以
這一根
紅K為依據
然後
喔
這樣看起來好像停力會到
然後
跟7
好
這個是
11加2
乘2
所以是
減
好
這邊就到了
所以這邊是一個
26點的停力
然後
這邊
OK
都是連續黑K
那就是等
反轉
就是
看這個
會不會被掌過
掌過的話
就進
加738
OK
那這邊馬上就進了一個
加738
那
因為這個是在夜盤的低點
就到這個地方
這個夜盤已經跌200點了
那
所以這邊是創新低
那停損一樣是設在創新低減1
所以是
停損是
然後
這邊是進一個
那
不會
直接設
這一個
呃
這個
黑K的低點
是因為如果這樣的話
停損是停損在725
那也是非常接近低點
那
還不如就設定創新低停損
會比較不容易停損
所以這邊的risk就是
所以是一個
三十六點
三十六點的停力
好然後這邊就順利的停力了三十六點在這個地方
然後
好然後這邊也是一個紅K
欸喔
這邊
喔這一根是
呃
七
七九五高點
然後在這個地方被掌過了嘛
所以是一個
加七九六
然後是以這一根為依據嘛
所以
停力是
欸
這一根為依據
停力是
呃
九
加二
十一
乘二
二十二點
所以停力是在
八一八
好
然後下一根就停力了
那這個
可能是跟程式單有關啦
因為前面
其實前面
其實前面有非常多個
一秒超過一百匹的
的
這個單子
的秒K
那
一秒
可以打超過一百匹
這個正常來說通常都是
都是程式單
那
所以這邊應該是
這邊應該是
這邊的這一個
四千多口的程式單
在這邊
就是
可能跟時間有關
可能跟價錢有關
做出來的一個停損
直接就是一千
一千三百多口
好
然後
這一根
大量的
這個
紅K
被疊破了
所以
這邊是進了一個
減
七九一的
空單
好
然後
這邊長過了
這根
這個
黑K
所以
這邊是一個
兩倍的
加
就是
原本的
七九一
被反向
變加
然後
這邊又重新
跌破了
所以
就停損在
七八八
然後
OK
這根
黑K
又被斬過
所以
這是一個
加
七九
四的
多單
然後
這一根
這根
黑K
紅K被疊破
所以
低點是
所以這邊是一個
兩倍的
-801
的空單
然後
OK
這個空單就停損了
所以是
兩倍的
-801
的空單
然後
停損
會停損在
這一個
+1
因為這個才是
局部的高點
所以
低點
是802
所以
這邊是一個
兩倍的
-801
的空單
然後
OK
這個空單
就停損了
所以是
兩倍的
-801
然後
停損
會停損在
這個+1
因為這個才是局部的高點
所以
停損
會停損在
所以這邊會
損在
然後
OK
這個
這一個
這一個是
所以它被疊破了
所以是一個
-808
的
空單
所以是一個
-808
的
空單
好
然後這一段是
連續停損
這個-808
的空單
損在
這個地方
是
損在
所以又是一個
扣14點
然後
OK
然後這個是
紅K
大量之後的
大量
同方向
紅K
所以這根
跌破之後
會進場
再
-822
然後
它的
Risk
是
7+2
然後
所以
停力距離是
乘2
是18
所以是
82-18
OK
好
然後這邊到804了嘛
所以這個是
停力了一個
18點
然後
OK
好
然後這邊到804了嘛
所以這個是
停力了一個
18點
然後
OK
然後到這個地方
就稍微
量減了
就進到
美股的盤中
OK
然後又進了一個
大量
那這個地方一樣
停損是會延長的
這個是一個
-814的空單
那
但是它停損
不會是在
因為
附近
有另一個
很近的高點
是
所以
停損會設在
那所以
它的
Risk
是
到
38-14
是
所以它的
停力距離
會是
所以
814-48
停力會設在
然後
這邊
這一單
就是
有
稍微等了一下
那
不過在這個地方
就
這個
幸運的停力在
所以最後這一單
是
+48
點
然後
後面
就
就到
收盤都
沒有再有
Q
以上的
大量
K棒
所以
這就是
今天的
副盤
好
就是這樣
其實
這種
有來回
非常非常多筆的盤
反而
對於我們這種短線
當中
教育者
是
比較友善
就是
交易的機會
會比較多啦
就是
會比那種
有時候
一整天
就是前一個小時
都
沒有訊號
或是只有一次或兩次訊號的
更多交易機會
然後
就是
好
一樣
是一個
實戰的交易
復盤
我想
大家
多看幾次應該都能夠了解
這個
這一套方法
基本邏輯大概是怎樣啦
就是
其實都是非常明確的規定
好
希望大家看完今天的影片也進步很多
大家拜拜